christophe prudhomme médecin urgentiste
responsable cgt bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france le personnel
médical est en effectif réduit en ce
moment c'est ce qui fait peur
aujourd'hui en cette période de vacances
oui il est clair que nous ne sommes pas
en capacité aujourd'hui de d'accepter
une augmentation du nombre
d'hospitalisations dans de bonnes
conditions
mais bon ce qui est un petit peu
irritant dans la période c'est la
difficulté qu'ont les citoyens pour se
faire tester vous savez là on parle
beaucoup du masque mais c'est un
ensemble de mesures qui permettra de
freiner l'épidémie c'est le port du
masque mais aussi c'est la possibilité
de se faire tester et de se faire tester
quand on change de région savez là on
nous parle beaucoup des frontières mais
y at-il une frontière entre la région
parisienne et finistère voilà dans le
finistère n'y avait pas de cas avant les
vacances les gens sont dues sont
d'autres régions sont arrivés dans le
finistère et nous avons un nombre de cas
important dans le finistère donc il faut
que les gens qui se déplacent au moindre
doute puisse se faire tester n'attendent
pas quinze jours trois semaines d'avoir
un rendez vous dans l'un des
laboratoires
l'urgence aujourd'hui est de donner les
moyens de pouvoir être testé dans la
journée quand on en a besoin et c'est
pas là dessus que le gouvernement
communique beaucoup aujourd'hui et ça ça
nous inquiète particulièrement
alors vous êtes médecin urgentiste est
ce que vous comptez vous constatez un
hôpital un half le patient attendre
jusqu'au 19
elle ces derniers jours non non il n'y a
pas un afflux de patients savez vous
avez comme dans votre reportage
précédent n'a en dramatiser les choses
non il ya un nombre de cas positifs ce
qui est normal puisque les gens
circulent de nouveau vont d'une région à
l'autre c'est est ce qu'on attendait ce
qu'on prévoyait maintenant il faut
contrôler contrôler effectivement la
dissémination du virus du fait de la
circulation des personnes et pour cela
c'est un ensemble de mesures qu'il faut
mettre en place aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
nous avons quelques hospitalisation qui
sont en nombre limité
heureusement parce qu'une bonne partie
des cas touchent les personnes jeunes
dont la plupart
des situations aux maladies peu grave
mais il est clair que dans les
rassemblements familiaux vous savez le
message qu'il faut donner c'est pas de
dire où là les jeunes regardent et ils
se rassemblent à l'extérieur en bande
non à l'extérieur le risque est faible
par contre quand les jeunes vont dans
une réunion de famille dans un lit local
clos c'est là qu'il va y avoir des
contaminations
les contaminations se compteraient peu à
l'extérieur se font quand on est dans un
local clos que ce soit les bars qui se
transforme en discothèque
les réunions de famille et puis aussi
surtout on n'en parle pas assez
les lieux de travail un certain nombre
de foyers indique l'auteur sont sur les
lieux de travail
donc il faut être particulièrement
vigilant dans les locaux clos et surtout
quand on y reste plusieurs heures
d'affilée est ce que la france les
hôpitaux font prêt pour une seconde
vague est ce que vous constatez que la
gestion de la première vague a servi de
leçon
non non absolument pas vous savez
aujourd'hui on assiste à des fermetures
de lits là il ya quelques jours nous
apprenions que les urgences de l'hôpital
de pertuis voyez à côté d'aix en
provence lille calais fermé la nuit
heureusement au dernier moment cette
mesure a été annulée mais voilà ça tombe
d'urgence restent fermées la nuit par
manque de personnel comme les urgences
de sisteron
nous manquons de lits vous savez que les
4000 saisonniers promis par le ministre
de la santé ne compense même pas le
nombre de lits fermés depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de monsieur macron donc voilà
donc on est dans des mesurettes
nous n'avons pas fait réellement le
retour d'expérience pour doter l'hôpital
de moyens massifs supplémentaire pour
qu'on soit en capacité l'hiver prochain
parce que savez chaque hiver que seuls
coronavirus où la grippe traditionnelle
nous sommes en situation de rupture à
l'hôpital public donc on ne peut pas
continuer avec ce manque de moyens en
personnel on lit en matériel said i'm an
l'hôpital aujourd'hui de quoi mon camp
nou 2 go de gand n'avons plus
suffisamment de gand et je viens d'avoir
une note de mon équipe opérationnelle
d'hygiène qui m'explique que pour
certains gestes
eh bien il ya pas besoin de porter des
gants on peut le faire à mains nues et
cela met ensuite les mains voilà où on
en est aujourd'hui et vous savez au
niveau là de
mesures qui ont été prises par l'europe
où les soignants nous sommes très déçus
que dans le quart des négociations qui
ont eu lieu avec les pays dits frugaux 1
une des mesures qui a été éliminée c'est
les mesures concernant la santé savais
qu'il y avait une certaine somme qui
était prévue pour mettre en place
effectivement un des entreprises de
santé qui soit capable de fournir le
matériel pour que l'europe soit
autosuffisante et ça a été rayée rayé du
plan soit disant historique vendus par
monsieur macron du plan européen de
relance
l'envoyé il ya des contradictions qui
sont partis comme en syrie tente pour
nos personnels de santé sur le terrain
alors on comprend que vous attendez un
univers compliqué la mesure est jusque
là écartés mais qu un recond finement
total comme en mars dernier vous
semblerait nécessaire en cas de
situation critique maintenant rare en
confinement total
nous l'avons critiquer c'est une mesure
moyenâgeuse qui n'étaient motivés que
par le manque de moyens donc la question
aujourd'hui c'est que nous ayons
suffisamment de tests suffisamment de
masse mais il n'est pas question de
revenir à un confinement total ce serait
une hérésie que ce soit en termes
sanitaires qu'en termes économiques
il faut qu'on soit en capacité de
détecter les patients et j'insiste
l'urgence aujourd'hui l'urgence et que
les gens puissent se faire tester dans
la journée quand ils ont besoin ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui en france
ce qui n'est pas le cas
le gouvernement nous avait promis au
mois de mai au moment du des confirmands
l'avait promis la capacité capacité de
700 vitesse par semaine nous sommes à
moins de 400 mille aujourd'hui deux mois
après pourquoi parce que nous manquons
de matériel des commandes n'ont pas été
faites
les laboratoires n'ont pas été dotée de
moyens et on tergiverse pour savoir si
on peut faire les tests en pharmacie si
les secouristes pourrait faire les
prélèvements mais il faut pouvoir faire
les prélèvements par tous et ainsi
sainte de faire les prélèvements
donc il faut se donner les moyens pour
effectivement dire aux gens quand ils
partent en vacances et qui viennent une
région où le virus circule et qui vont
dans une région où il ya peu de virus et
bien au moindre doute qu'ils se fassent
tester avant de partir et s'ils sont
positifs et bien ils partent pas c'est
ça aujourd'hui le message qu'il faut
transmettre à la population et on l'a
bien entendu merci
coup christophe prudhomme d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes un médecin
urgentiste responsable cgt